hi guys hi guys my name is Tamara Jaber
and I'm Cody Meltzer I ever just saw and
Cody also just saw two as well we just
saw power Riverdale the where the Archie
gang becomes Power Rangers it just felt
a lot like the CW show Riverdale with
Power Rangers there is like this we can
talk about Rangers that's what it was
really called not the original one with
Ivan ooze although I would really upset
that they didn't have an Ivan ooze
reference I was looking for it no but we
watched that before this mm-hmm
yeah our feel because we needed to make
sure that we you know could compare to
the classics my major problem was the
new Power Rangers movie there was not
enough parachuting air boarding you were
rolling I did really they didn't have
what's their names
Kronk and Scholl or whatever their dad
yeah I can't remember their names I
scroll scroll and come now I'm pissed
I just realized now I'm not right now I
hate the movie review not reviews up not
not review that in the video to the new
Power Rangers this was a blast it was so
much it was a blast
I think it that be trailer did a huge
disservice I thought I was like so much
cheese I like the design of anything I
also saw that acting was terrible and
then everything was like all of my
worries dissolved when I was watching
this I feel like tree talking about the
original drive is the original moving oh
yeah no I mean I I still have some
problems with some of the design it's
still the whole movie is as dark as the
trailer is in terms of like the visual
like I know that's the thing we're all
doing now but it's like there were some
times where just so dark I'm like what
am I looking at like I don't understand
what's on the screen everything took
place at night it even very the base
edge would still Eveleigh shadowed I
mean they're a team of rainbow colors
and it would have a nice obscene the
color a little slice a spoilers at least
to some extent
definitely ah so the beginning of the
movie there's like a new origin kind of
for the power
ranges the stomachs it's not really new
because I mean we all know we all know
the Power Rangers and we all know the
whole like that the lineage of this
several different Power Rangers even
after the original one so many yeah you
know many and like at least four
different Dino themed ones um yeah
there's space or ninjas time cops at one
point there's like a karate master yeah
man if he's a guinea pig they explain
this like Zordon one of the original
Power Rangers or not original but at
least one like he's the one before them
yeah their suits look more like the
species of alien that Jordan and his
people work yeah I like I really enjoyed
the intro I really enjoyed those
orienting because it was like we have we
had two scenes back-to-back bit like had
no explanations given the Cenozoic era
dinosaur time Power Rangers died Bryan
Cranston is one of them and the next
massive explosion meteor then suddenly
cut to he was putting a cow in a locker
room and then one of them gives it a car
and gets in a horrible car wreck and
that was the first two scenes of the
movie so there is a bit of like ah
what's going on take it together it's
not my job
oh no yeah I think it was a little
jolting for me really a little bit yeah
also I would you played down for the
ride I was like let's do this speaking
about being down for the ride how many
car wrecks can one movie have there were
three different times with someone who
flipped a car the who and oh my god that
rain one yeah and this was at a certain
point this was more like Fast and the
Furious Power Rangers right what I liked
a lot about the movie was that they took
a lot of the classic like old characters
and a lot of the things like they kept a
lot of them they kept the Power Rangers
names they still have Rita but they kind
of updated and modernized it and brought
their own taste to it like when two of
the original Power Rangers show up in
the movie and everyone like a dude in
the audience they were like yes
seriously it was like everyone really
yeah there they are we recognized that
thing and we thought we all believed in
each other what is reading uh not
children right yeah okay there was no
not jewelry dark moments and Mary
moment deceiving though where is like
Deadpool yeah okay you don't wear your
kid to this comic book movie but this is
a little deceiving
of course the scariest part of the movie
over corporate capitalism because I
don't know how much Krispy Kreme paid to
be in this movie the entire plot hinges
on Krispy Kreme there is literally an
entire scene just discussing Krispy
Kreme Rita Rudner ha ha ha there's a
moment where Rita rounder and Gilda
Radner are talking in a Christmas tree
it's like I'm divorced with using
delicious salsa literally eat the Krispy
Kremes y'all I'm putting it in the
middle of the pipe space was a script
written out and they were like this
would be hilarious and Krispy Kreme or
must Krispy Kreme like here are demand
this is what you have to do I honestly
don't know that's the true question of
Christmas bringing it to clothing they
all had very specific looks about them
in the past but what you would imagine
which is the mall dressing in their
colors which they didn't actually do
that much I told camera all the way
there
that I was going to be pick if alpha 5
didn't say III at least once and he said
it twice he said it ran and I held
cameras hand when the first one happened
I almost cried yeah yeah cuz I was ready
to start a hashtag not my alpha cuz like
you know but yeah it was a beautiful
moment
I like this alpha funnier alpha more
directly rather than mic funny because
he's a weird robot feared but I'm a
different thing design wise that I saw I
was like I don't like this I like this I
like it I don't like doesn't like and I
what I like it super on me and on me and
so did or infinite Zordon as played by
one of those push push pin things I wish
I had Donovan foot it out I really
thought that there was gonna be too much
cheese and I also probably acting was
going to be terrible in the trailer one
of them says we're all outcasts and that
that was didn't even make it into the
film and I wasn't bothered by their
acting many kinds there was a couple not
merely past the original oh my god like
that they could they could actually act
no offense for the original hi guys um
we know
you watch brought up you fans big thing
if you're going to hold on to like the
tangibility of Power Rangers I think
there needs to be some humorous kam
penis to it I like guardians of the
galaxy style like kind of campy humor
that was great yeah I think know one
thing that did bother me and I guess
this goes into the darkness is they each
have their like backstory which I
understand it's a very power ranger
thing it's a very like run it just fits
in with this world but it was a little
much it was a little heavy-handed for me
it like short I think that the revenge
porn flop I just fellas we're a little
weird well I was also weird saying too
because Kimberly is the bad person in
that story but then later they like drop
a thing on the car and she goes back to
Tim can you get and it's like wait you
put is yours up you were the bad brother
this you learn nothing yours
nothing Timberland girl that was eyeball
right I was weird I was like somebody
didn't pay attention to script or not
point yeah I agree
I do you think that part of that is
because something I liked about the
movie is that they did a much better job
of especially compared to like other
movies about teams that don't know each
other coming together is they did a much
better job of creating that kind of
initial conflict of these people not
knowing each other some of them not
really caring about each other actively
not wanting to be there and then making
it them actually kind of more
realistically bond how realistic can you
get with alien superhero karate masters
I mean apparently pretty good yeah it is
a relative I mean like it felt like they
were bonded the pacing was excellent I
think like from this hot like everything
hit its mark really well they found out
they were Power Rangers and then they
got to know each other they were able to
more than me so everything like really
fit in well and it wasn't like ah patna
time they really rushed over that yeah
so it's a fun movie it's all fun and
games and so young Earth Creationism so
what happens is they do at least admit
that the world is at least 65 million
years old okay but so the Zords right we
all know the Zords you guys a
Tyrannosaurus Rex saber-toothed tiger
Triceratops Mastodon and the parrot axle
and then in the TV show the dragon uh
you know you know the classic dinosaurs
the dragon
but the problem is so like the problem
with all of those is a those are all
dinosaurs from like different time
periods and two mammals and one dinosaur
that we've recently found out doesn't
actually exist it's a teenage version of
other dinosaurs
I believe don't write me paleontologist
so that's fine but in this movie they
explained that the reason why the Zords
are all dynast all dinosaurs there is
because in the time period from the
beginning of the movie which I believe
as I said was a Cenozoic era when when
Giordano like is on earth they chose the
form of the biggest most powerful
creatures on the planet so what they're
saying is that the woolly man or the
mastodon totally different animal and
the saber-tooth Tiger existed at the
same time as the pterodactyl and the
Tyrannosaurus Rex and the Triceratops
which isn't true the beginning of the
movie even has the explains the whole
comment thing about the death of the
dinosaurs so even the movie itself this
thing they didn't exist in the same time
but also it and that is a gateway to
young Earth Creationism which is not OK
so a point that I want to speak about
that was like a hot topic issue for this
film is Billy who was always spectrum of
autism um this is not something that I
feel like I can talk about like super
knowledgeable because it's not something
that I struggle with I just faculty say
I liked him it's Kendra what did this
part the perfect representation of
autism I honestly don't know let me hear
your thoughts especially you know if you
have autism or if your own spectrum I
think just like I always say when it
comes to like you know any other type of
like progressive character installment
at least they're there I guess at least
they're trying to put that kind of those
kinds of things forward it's the orange
Ranger if you are a fan of the Power
Rangers at like from some likes like og
fan like no one goes told your fan no
not one of those not one of those
bandwagon Power Ranger fans stick around
after the credits yeah that's all I want
to say you probably know why search your
feelings but it's so good good a bless
I had a glass watching it it's not
Shawshank Redemption but it's a great
it's great for what it is great to be
fair if Shawshank Redemption had had
Power Rangers I might have liked it more
I love that smell
I know I did too I was kidding okay good
job Go Go Power Rangers to the theater
set a new shield plating not watching
I'm watching Oh however I will throw it
up hard though yeah just like me right
now hey workin time